and so right now I have2 billion do
paths what's the worst case scenario if
you do it anything that damages your
reputation is irreversible cuz you only
get one reputation and you literally
can't bankrupt yourself out [__]
it one of the hardest decisions in
entrepreneurship is deciding which path
to follow especially when you have two
or multiple good paths I'm at a point in
my career where I do have a very large
decision that I need to commit to for
multiple years and I've been spending
basically every waking hour trying to
gather more data to make the right
decision one of my favorite things to do
when I do have big decisions is to
change my environment and I think it
happens multiple times my favorite place
to think is actually on planes I often
have very few distractions when I'm on
planes and I quite literally get
perspective like I'm flying up and I'm
looking down at the earth I feel like I
always make really good decisions when
I'm in the air and uh it's actually
something that I like really look
forward to you know what I've been
waiting for since I've been married
going to Chili's bonda chilies I had
like a seizure honestly I would go
because I don't mind I don't care about
the style of the restaurant but I do not
like their food I think they have
amazing chips great salsa and the
fajitas are strong I hate that you go
hard on this in front of people because
then behind the closed doors you're like
yeah it's not that good if there's any
time like in the fine establishments
that I go to that we Bunch you now like
five times like we'll go and she'll be
like it sucks right it sucks say it say
it it's not as good as the finest dining
in the world just say it I'll be like
yes it's not as good she's like see see
and then that's it for the rest of my
life your chil [__] and you get like a
stomach ache from it and then you're
like who are you talking about here yeah
who are we talking about I think you're
telling me your
story so we just landed in San Diego and
we are going to reals event which is a
big publicly traded brokerage for real
estate agents our really close friend
Chiron svat is the president of the
company he invited us out we're probably
going to have dinner with him we're
going to speak there tomorrow I will be
making a presentation to help real
estate agents sell more houses but it
will not be about real estate it'll uh
either soccer be great or somewhere in
between Le's like I'm just how do I how
do I stop doing all these routines I'm
like I can't even start I like tried to
smoke cigarettes to get addicted to them
and I was like I just it was too hard it
was just too hard to stick with it it's
like every morning it's like whatever I
[Music]
forgot the hardest part about growth is
that the better you get the bigger you
get the bigger the opportunities are and
the better they are I think the easiest
slip Miss test is to determine how big
of the opportunity is worth your
attention so right now 10x is kind of my
my lpness text like we're at 100 it's
got to be a billion or more for it to be
something that I want to dedicate time
to and so right now I have what I would
consider to be2 billion doll paths
they're very different relatively
irreversible one has potentially more
upside but more risk the other one is
more certain but has lower upside
there's lots of things that can make a
decision you're reversible there if it's
a certain percentage of your net worth
or capital I don't like making those
kinds of bets this is a quote from Shan
svat buddy of mine he said never want to
bet the empire for a pot of gold you bet
what you have and need for something you
don't have and don't need it's never a
good bet anything that damages your
reputation is irreversible cuz you only
get one reputation and you literally
can't bankrupt yourself out of a bad
reputation you can't make take
reputational risk where there's only
downside now if I were to say like I
want to support this cause I might piss
off some people but it'll move me
towards a different group of people so
then in that case that's that's a
trade-off more than it's a risk and so
that's it's different than what I'm
talking about here and then you just
have time you know time that you can't
get back now every every like moment you
spend always has the opportunity cost of
what you could have done with that time
to get a higher return I think the
number presentation I have on YouTube is
about that concept is the only base
thing we have is time and we make trades
for stuff and so the people who are
better at trading it for more stuff get
more stuff there is this story that Tony
Robbins told that I really like that
just kind of Illustrated this image is
that like rich people make bets where
they can't lose on either way like so
there's this guy who knows that nickels
nowaday are made with nickel or whatever
the the material they make nickel with
is more valuable than the cost of a
nickel this billionaire he knows has
taken the nickel he's putting it in
storage as an investment because the day
that they change or remove that nickel
from currency cuz it makes no sense
he'll melt it and get 40% on his money
but there are investments that are high
return low risk you want to find those
bets how's it going I don't want to
you're good man what's up I I'm a
treasury founder we just find banks in
the US that literally pay the highest
rates on cash well give me your card I
don't have a card I I got L here take a
picture of me and message me and then
the guy who managed my linkon will get
it there you go oh we got to get a good
lighting there it is do it right now so
I can tell him I'll do it right now yeah
if we can get more C more return on our
cash we're in a Hot Zone a Hot Zone of
recognition what's all like
entrepreneurial people looks like it
this gentleman no half measures that's
right he knows I'll tell you that story
man we're running gym launch making a
lot of money I got asked to speak at
this like personal trainer conference
and I was like yeah sure I'll I'll talk
like I wasn't being asked to speak I
wasn't making content like this so like
it wasn't like a normal I was like sure
I'll come talk and I was like so what do
you want to do he's like well I figur
you just like give a lot of value and
then you can you know present your thing
or whatever and I was like okay cool
cool I I made this really long
presentation that was just like very
very good and then at the end I had the
full presentation webinar of how to how
to sell like that I used to sell it
before and I was like You guys probably
don't need to see all this stuff right
like okay you get it like personal
training you know it's important you got
to know how to sell got to understand
the systems uh at the end I was like
yeah and here's the price and I dropped
it and I was like you I just I just went
as fast as I could through it and I
didn't even I said it like I'm saying it
right now I didn't like actually say it
and so then I revealed the price and so
I did what would have been a 90-minute
presentation pitch in like 15 minutes
after giving 3 hours plus of value so I
was like this should make sense I give a
shitload of value and then I'll just
soft toss it right and I got so much
resistance from the crowd it was the
biggest flop of a pration I've ever G my
entire life I don't even think I think I
made two sales I it was nothing right
now I had done a half measure and so
it's either sell or don't sell don't be
in between you either give value or you
sell [__] don't try and mix them if we
want to make commitments in anything or
you're trying to go all in on a decision
one of the best ways to do that is to
eliminate the possibility of going back
on it a lot of people spend most of
their lives being half in half out which
to me is just not in at all it just
gives them an excuse to feel like
they're making progress when they really
aren't there's a lot of books that talk
about going pro going all in burning the
boats and I think they all kind of go
along the same point which is that
sometimes you have to make a bet and be
willing to be wrong knowing that if you
make no bet you're guaranteed to be
wrong but yeah for tomorrow everybody
there knows more about selling houses
than I do and my proof point of that is
that they have all sold more houses than
I have so what am I going to teach them
about selling houses right I think it
would be silly for me to try and compete
on that cuz there's other speakers
who've both done it and been there more
than me so I feel like that' be a
terrible position to take what I am
going to do is say if I were to start
here's how I would win but if Selling
Houses means winning it'll apply here's
my girlfriend Riley how's it going
Michael Michael nice to meet you sorry
my hands are cold appreciate it dude
you're killing the game man very nice to
meet you night nice meeting you too
Riley right see you guys when I was in
high school I read this book called how
to make friends and influence people and
I think I think the second chapter or
something is call people by their name
it's their favorite word in the whole
language and I was like oh that's
interesting your favorite word in the
entire language is your own name so you
love hearing that word more than any
other word why should say that a lot of
times if somebody likes that word think
about this from a leverage perspective
if you haven't seen somebody in a year
and then you show up at a conference and
you're like Steve and he doesn't
remember your name he loses all aage
you're the good guy and so you have so
much more leverage in the conversation
for remember thank you for calling
reservation center got to see if I can
get in there with a tank top and Water
Sandals thank you for calling Steak
House Amy speaking how can we help you
Amy how are you today hello am I'm doing
okay how are you I'm good quick question
for you I have reservation at 7:30
what's the dress code we don't turn
anyone away unless you're wearing the
following board shorts swimsuits and
tank tops for well if you've never
turned anyone away before then I might
just have to risk it cuz I can't go back
to my hotel in
time no okay I'm going to say Amy said
it was okay yeah no problem I'll get
that sent over though and let them know
he should be okay thank you so much Amy
you're a lifesaver you're like that with
the ice cream so we're on our way to an
ice cream shop and it's it's closing
like at the time we're about to get
there leelo she was like we should call
to make sure that like we can get in and
I was like hey how's it going my wife
needs ice cream I'm going to be in the
dog house I was like what are the
chances one in a million that you guys
can stay up 5 minutes later so I can get
some ice cream I was like I'll be in and
out I'll be the fastest ice cream man
you've ever seen and they were
like okay but you just can't tell anyone
I like it I will take you to the Grave
except for this content that I'm making
right
now and she let us in and we got the
Sundays I've done a lot of phone sales
and I've done a lot of inperson sales
and there's a lot of mini skills that
you learn in sales that are useful in
every other environment where you need
to get people to do something that you
want them to do the ideal way of doing
is getting them to want to do the thing
that you want them to do rather than and
having them feel like they are doing you
a favor the way that you ask the tone
that you ask the laughs that you make
the jokes that you make all of those
micro things I do those things so that
the person on the other end feels like
if they see me in person it will be a
positive experience and they want to
have that reward and so they are willing
to push or bend the rules a little bit
so that I can do whatever it is that I'm
trying to do or get in a restaurant or
dessert or whatever it is people do nice
things when they're in nice moods so
it's like get them in a good mood first
then ask for the nice
[Music]
thing said you made half the
presentation last night yeah I kind of
have this like process that sort of
works I'll like outline what I'm going
to say like far in advance and then the
day before I'll change half of it oh we
get the we get the VIP entrance
okay
and then we noticed at your presentation
about 300 plus slides yeah I finished it
like 20 minutes ago yeah it looks good
oh looks good yeah and if it doesn't
I'll survive okay usually I get more of
my adrenaline now and by the time I get
on stage it's like I'm done with it kind
of thing it's always directly
proportional to the prep yeah this will
be the first time I've talked about any
of the stuff that I'm talking about in a
keyo so I like I love this tall boy D
this is great get a little bit of sugar
a little bit of caffeine
a little bit of
delicious and a little bit of uh [__] it
how many
people
350 I had 100 slides he has 220 I have
300 oh my God 300 slides I'm looking
forward to it oh thank you have you ever
done a real estate audience no I don't
think so I'm not I don't talk to real
estate agents it's going to be useless
for them they'll be like what a waste of
an
hour [__]
talk up from my friend Alex
[Applause]
horos a lot of you guys already know how
to win because you know how to lose so
flip it you guys know how to win better
than I could ever tell you you measure
your success by whether you completed
the actions that would make it
unreasonable that you will not fail and
then you succeed by default and everyone
here has things that they've written
down from many of the talks of things
that you want to do or want to think
about or whatever I would encourage you
to make that list of things that you
will do and then when you go back to the
same condition your same home your same
house your same Market your same
whatever you change your behavior and
then that will show that you learned and
you took one step to becoming the person
that you ultimately want to
be this stuff is all top of mine in
terms of making actions that would make
it unreasonable that I fail with a
billion dollar decision is because
that's actually a decision I'm making
right now I'm at a point in my career
where I have enough what I would
consider singles doubles triples that I
have decided to take a bigger swing I'll
either win or I'll learn same as you so
from the bottom of our heart Alex you
impacted our life thank you man we
appreciate you thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you all I want to do
when I up
01 of you at
all you can be dude dude you can be 100x
you stop it thank you Alex you're good
Chris very nice to meet you appreciate
you Katie appreciate you photo with you
and Katie yeah sure it's still tra bro I
followed you since you had about 50,000
subscribers I still back here to see you
I'm going to earn that hat I bought one
I'll go wear it someday thank
God I love seeing mosy nation of the
wild I love the hustle I love everyone
coming up and and and sharing their
their stories like that always makes my
day I would say though do it in a place
where you won't you know get put in
handcuffs for sneaking in come up when
you see me in public if you can I'm
happy to say hi take pictures whatever
don't go into areas where you're not
supposed to go in order to try and hang
out because it usually just doesn't end
well the crowd is loving you very nice
to meet you thank you so much appreciate
it so that was that was great I did my
keynote earlier in the day I think
people liked it they may not have I
think they sat through regardless and I
think we're probably going to have the
afternoon probably a couple hours
probably walk around and then we'll head
back to Las Vegas can see
that see I almost
content
[Music]
yep back in the day when I had one-on
ones there was a one guy who I was like
so like what have you done for personal
Improvement like what do you you know
have you he's like yeah you know it was
so crazy like I realized if I if I don't
watch Netflix as much while I'm working
I get like so much more done I was like
there's so many things wrong with that
statement you were telling me probably
just like just level one of idsc level
two of idsc is that like you mentioned
that you're doing that you were watching
nflix in general while you were working
point three is that you didn't actually
say you were going to stop you just said
that you cut back on how much Netflix
you were watching while you were working
and I just like there's so many
stupidities interwoven into so few words
I was flabbergasted so you're more
productive when you don't watch Netflix
movies all not as much yeah yeah okay as
much as many shows in a row while you're
being paid at your job yeah it's been
[Music]
great that's pretty that is pretty oh
damn so if you're at the crossroads
between one decision that you're trying
to choose between two different paths if
it's the first go round I would
encourage you to take the lower risk
path that has a higher chance of success
if it's a business there are stories of
just unbelievable entrepreneurs but what
you don't he is the tens of thousands of
entrepreneurs who make that massive bet
and then lose everything and lose five
eight years of their lives if you are
going to make the big swing and kudos to
you it's an absolutely personal decision
burn the boats go all in fully commit
eliminate Alternatives no half measures
because what I can guarantee you is that
if you are going after the big swing the
way to guarantee that it does not work
is to go half in so if you're going to
win make it unreasonable that anything
that was in your control was not
controlled for and then only lose for
things that were not under your control
what do you think top five for me I go
Matrix all time I'd be willing to put
Dark Knight is number two it's just like
he's such a good villain it's just like
he was just the perfect villain the
intro scene is just like one of the
alltime best scenes ever I really like
old but I do like Gladiator Russell Pro
do you have one that's not like action
heavy probably my favorite comedy [__]
no it's too hard 40 Old Virgin Wedding
Crashers super bad and surprise uh
bridesmaides I cried during bridesmaides
it's like I couldn't breathe I was dying
yeah I mean I went cuz a buddy of mine
at the job that I was at was like let's
go see it and I was like fine so I like
had a couple drinks and like went to the
movie theater and I like was
hyperventilating cuz I couldn't [__]
stop laughing